-Here now performing
"Here It Is Christmas Time"
From Marvel's
"The Guardians Of The Galaxy
Holiday Special" on Disney plus,
give it up
for Kevin Bacon and Old 97s.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ When we are born
we are swaddled and suckled ♪
♪ Whispered to, fussed over,
tickled and cuddled ♪
♪ When we grow up
things get muddled ♪
♪ And here it is,
Christmas time ♪
♪ Will you stop by
for a piece of delicious ♪
♪ Peach pie while I tell you
my yuletide wishes? ♪
♪ You can help me
do the dishes ♪
♪ And here it is,
Christmas time ♪
-♪ We all want someone ♪
♪ To love us and hold us ♪
♪ To curl up alongside ♪
♪ When nights are the coldest ♪
♪ We all want someone ♪
♪ Who will hug us and kiss us ♪
♪ All I want is you
for Christmas ♪
-♪ Let us examine
the holiday spirit ♪
♪ Let the small kids sing
so we can all hear it ♪
♪ Light up a fire
and pull the chair near it ♪
♪ 'Cause here it is,
Christmas time ♪
-♪ We all want someone ♪
♪ Who will love us and hold us ♪
♪ To curl up alongside ♪
♪ When nights are the coldest ♪
♪ We all want someone ♪
♪ Who will hug us and kiss us ♪
♪ All I want is you
for Christmas ♪
♪♪
-♪ When we are born
we are swaddled and suckled ♪
♪ Whispered to, fussed over,
tickled and cuddled ♪
♪ When we grow up
things get muddled ♪
♪ And here it is,
Christmas time ♪
-♪ We all want someone ♪
♪ Who will love us and hold us ♪
♪ To curl up alongside ♪
♪ When nights are the coldest ♪
♪ We all want someone ♪
♪ Who will hug us and kiss us ♪
♪ All I want is you
for Christmas ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, come on!
That's what I'm talking about.
Hey, bud.
Nice to see you.
Thank you.
Old 97s, Kevin Bacon.
Check out Marvel's
"The Guardians of the Galaxy
Holiday Special"
only Disney plus.